tipping culture has gone too far we've
all seen this building for a long time
it happens everywhere any store you go
to you go to the cafe you go to the grab
and go restaurant once it happened to me
at a dut shop the clerk is there and you
complete your transaction and then he
flips the iPad around and he says oh
just pess a few buttons plays Dumb do
whatever you want to do that's fine okay
yesterday this reached a whole new level
I was on my way to Cornell I spoke at
Cornell last night it's going to be
aired tonight on the yaf YouTube channel
but I'm on my way to Cornell I'm at the
airport there's a little store called
Cheo Express so I go in to get a drink
and there is no employee in the stop I I
go I reach in I say I want an IC tea
there's no I te okay that's fine I get a
perryer so I I take it to the self
checkout kiosk and I
scan the perryer and then it says to me
how much would you like to tip
there was nobody I could have tipped
there was only the robot the robot asked
me for a tip 18% 20% maybe
25% and now I'm kicking
myself because I did not tip even though
I'm fairly certain that the robots will
take over the whole country so
now that means I could have curried good
favor with our future robot overlords
but but instead I did not and so now I
am wait waiting for those random robot
overlords to come and exact their
Revenge right now go to hall.com nesk
Wes with everything going on in the
world there is no better time to build a
daily habit of prayer and meditation
building a habit of prayer can help you
cultivate an attitude of gratitude
focusing on what you are thankful for
can increase positive emotions and
improve overall well-being also you owe
it to God to pray so you should pray
hello is the number one Christian Prayer
app in the United States it's helped so
many people to maintain a daily prayer
routine it can help you too download the
app for free at hall.com you can set
prayer reminders and track your progress
along the way not sure where to start
check out father Mike schmitz's Bible in
a year available on the hallo app for
brief daily readings and Reflections or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim cisel
even some worldclass athletes with hallo
you can customize a personal prayer plan
that works for you listen wherever you
are with downloadable offline sessions
using hallow to connect with others who
share your beliefs and values can
provide a sense of belonging support and
Foster a sense of community hallow just
added a section on their app called
prayers for peace for Israel they have
several prayers to help people pray for
peace in Israel download Hall hall.com
kwes get an exclusive three months free
that is three months absolutely free at
hall.com
Hunter Biden Hunter Biden has a new opad
in USA
Today headline is I fought to get sober
political weaponization of my addiction
hurts more than me my struggles and my
mistakes have been fodder for a vile and
sustained disinformation campaign
against my father and in all that
annihilation of my
reputation hunter in USA Today okay here
are the key parts and this tells you a
lot about where the bidens are he says
my struggles and my mistakes have been
fodder for this violence sustain
disinformation campaign against Biden
and all out annihilation of my
reputation through high-pitched but
fruitless Congressional investigations
hold on put a pause there fruitless we
got the Smoking Gun we got the we got
the confirmation from you that you are
the bagman for the Biden family that you
shake down leaders around the world
selling American influence that you get
money from them and then you pay at
least 10% if not 50% of it to the big
guy fruitless investigations we know
that you had these Shady business bus
deals wired to you using your father's
address as the beneficiary address
fruitless
investigations FR totally fruitless and
more recently he writes criminal charges
for possessing an unloaded gun for 11
days five years ago charges that appear
to be the first of their kind ever
brought in the history of Delaware yeah
you you were being charged for that
because the prosecutors were giving you
a sweetheart deal to not charge you for
any of the serious crimes the serious
crimes of public interest go Way Beyond
the gun charge the serious crimes of
public interest go to racketeering
serious crimes of public interest go to
failing to register as a foreign agent
serious crimes of foreign interest
involve your father getting bribed when
he was the vice president of the United
States these are these charges these are
trumped up charges yeah because they
didn't bring any of the real charges
against you this was the way to get you
off the hook bro then he goes on and
this is the key what troubles me forget
about me it's not just about attacks on
me Hunter no no what troubles me is the
demonization of
addiction of human Frailty using me as
its Avatar and the devastating
consequences it has for the millions
struggling with addiction desperate for
a way out and being
bombarded by the denigrating and near
constant coverage of me and my addiction
on Fox News more airtime than GOP
Presidential candidate Ronda santis gets
and in the New York Post an average of
two stories a day over the past year
yeah because the New York store the New
York Post broke the story not just of
your addiction and all the weird photos
and videos that you put on your computer
that you took yourself and that you left
at this repair shop and it was
suppressed by big
Tech but of your crimes your financial
and political crimes this oped to me is
so desperate for a man who Hunter
Biden's done a lot of desperate things
this to me seems like the most desperate
example they got this guy dead and by
they I mean we the conservatives we've
got this guy dead to rights on
corruption this is his last ditch ever
to say hey it's it's addiction I'm
suffering from a disease yeah I listen I
I know addicts addiction is very hard
it's hard to get over addiction to
alcohol or
drugs but it's look we make jokes about
it you make jokes about political people
oh yeah this one's a little fat this
one's a little bit of a Booz Hound this
one's a womanizer but it's man it's all
of it it's all of it it's the it's the
hookers and it's the crack sure and it's
the but more than that it's the it's the
painting you took up painting and now
you're selling your artwork for half a
million dollars a piece for your Doodles
your little Doodles that you do that a
5-year-old could do I'm not making fun
of your art Hunter Biden I'm making fun
of your of your graft I'm making fun of
your con because art collection first of
all is one of the most prominent and
well-known avenues for money laundering
that there is and nobody thinks that
your ridiculous Doodles are worth half a
million dollars it's obviously just a
way to keep the con going now that
you've got a little more attention on
you and it's hard for you to go shake
down CCP officials in China or oligarchs
in
Ukraine but it's also the pitching up 10
for the the big
guy it's also the introducing Joe to
your business partner and then Joe your
father W's vice president pres saying to
your business partner I'm really glad
you and Hunter hooked up yeah that's
good I hope you enjoyed that lunch with
the president of China today yeah yeah I
hope you guys do good business together
it's your father calling into 20 plus
phone calls it's your father sending
tens of thousands of emails under
pseudonyms when he's Vice President of
the United States many of which were
were to conduct business with your
business partner in your shady overseas
contacts they got this guy dead to
rights and the best thing he can do is
say
heyy you're mocking addicts
this is like John fedman when John
anytime you criticize John fedman he
says you're mocking stroke victims
mocking stroke first of all man people
were mocking John fedman long before his
stroke two if you have had a stroke and
you you're mentally debilitated you
should resign from the Senate it's no
knock on you it's not to say you're an
immoral person because you've had a
health problem but you're just not up to
the job and you should
resign but three no one does not mock
stroke victims broadly one go was after
you because you're a kid who kid he's a
grown man obviously now but since he was
a kid he never really had that serious a
job he was getting handouts from Mom and
Dad he had a radical political agenda
he's not the workingclass hero he pres
presented himself as that's what people
are and whenever people knock him for
any reason he's oh it's you're just
knocking me for my disability same thing
here with Hunter Biden even more
ridiculous from Hunter Biden boy what a
great clip that was now hey I know what
you think
that's a nice Studio on the road Michael
I know it is it looks pretty nice the
second thing you're thinking is I ought
to subscribe yes you should ring the
bell we'll see you next time